is mark wahlberg's daughter dating will
ferrell's son she's growing up too fast
but dusty and i have this kodak thing on
lockdown it's clear mark has his teenage
daughter on lockdown
nobody is a good type or sort for me you
know i'm so overprotective the
46-year-old actor went into protective
daddy mode when the conversation turned
to allowing his eldest daughter ella ray
to date on an upcoming episode of ellen
i found some disturbing news today
about his kids
that well about his oldest boy who i
thought was a lovely lad until i
realized that he is in some sort of form
of communication with my oldest child
in what form what in what form they're
following each other on instagram
but what i don't understand is how could
my daughter's on instagram when i've had
her phone for 45 days i want her to be
able to have fun but i also want to make
sure that i protect her
especially with social media and stuff
like that
but mark says he would give his little
girl permission to start a relationship
with one young man
it's inevitable that she will be with
somebody right and so if it could be
somebody like will i would be happy wow
you know that she's in good hands that's
his name will your son no magnus magnus
too bad will didn't leave the best
impression of his 13 year old son no
he's a good boy he's a good boy he's a
good boy
is he i mean well
other than the fact that he likes to
purchase knives on the internet he's a
good one
so
keep your cutlery
locked up yeah if he comes over yeah
maybe you don't want her hanging out
with magnus i mean other than that he
seems like a sweet boy than that yeah
[Music]
you